Citizen Kane came out in 1941 and has
become one of the most talked-about and
widely referenced films of all time it's
so popular and so influential that it's
essentially become a phrase well you
know that movie was pretty good but it
wasn't Citizen Kane or anything or you
know I wasn't expecting it to be Citizen
Kane it was alright or that film is the
Citizen Kane of crime dramas it's so
well known that it's become a part of
our pop culture it's become a part of
the way we speak
Morrison Welles directed the film he
stars in it he took part in the
screenplay and the producing the
production of the film was historic at
the time because he was mostly known for
his theater work and that's where he
felt most comfortable and that's where
he really wanted to maintain himself but
Hollywood kept trying to court him and
get him to make films for them and he
took part in a very controversial
contract that essentially gave him
complete creative control final cut
everything they couldn't have people on
set despite the fact that RKO Pictures
would sometimes try to get people on set
to see what they were doing he had so
much control something that was
unprecedented at the time especially for
someone as young as he was this film in
every way could have been a complete
financial and critical disaster and yet
it has endured as a classic of our times
for some though Citizen Kane can be a
very daunting film to watch or talk
about in fact for me sitting here it's
rather imposing just to just make a
review of it because so many other
people have analyzed this film from back
to front
for decades there's really nothing new
that I can say about the movie I can
simply tell you my experience with it
and how I've come to really love the
film because when I was younger and I
saw it for the first time I just really
didn't get it it didn't really mesh with
me you hear so much about this film and
so many people hype it up endlessly it's
constantly on lists as one of the best
films of
time or the best film ever made many
well-known critics have named it their
favorite film and so you sit down
expecting to be transported away to a
world in which you are so blown away
that you can no longer speak and you're
so hyped and you're so ready and it's
just a really technically well-made film
that's masterfully directed and so
impressive for what Orson Welles had
going for him at the time in regards to
what he had done before or what he had
not done before on a technical level
cinematography music this being Bernard
Herrmann's first film score acting story
structure it's unprecedented for its
time and easily my favorite film of the
1940s it's such an incredibly well made
movie but I can totally understand how
anyone would watch this and say I mean
it's good but like why is everyone say
this is the best movie ever made it's
kind of boring like I can totally see
people thinking that because it does not
follow common story structure it's not
like a enthralling story so to speak
it's not like you sit and watch like 12
Angry Men and you get so invested in
these characters despite the fact that
it is an excellent character study and
you can look at its story and its
depiction of that excess and see it so
many times today a thousand times over
in various celebrities as I was watching
the film most recently a couple days ago
to prepare for this review I thought a
lot about Michael Jackson and his
Neverland Ranch filled with animals
his pet chimpanzee all of the money and
random things he would buy he would buy
statues he essentially was a modern-day
Citizen Kane but it's understandable
that anyone might watch this film and
just not appreciate it because it's been
hyped so much and it's very dangerous
for a film to to gain such notoriety
because you watch it expecting to be
transported to another planet or
something and it's just a really damn
great movie that was far ahead of its
time in regards to what it was trying to
do Orson Welles later said one of my
favorite quotes about filmmaking ever
when someone asked him
how he was so audacious enough to make a
film like this at that point in his life
he said ignorant sheer ignorance you
know there's no confidence to equal it
it's only when you know something about
a profession I think that you're timid
or careful which is so true when I was a
kid making short films we didn't think
about the meaning we didn't wonder what
people might think of what we were
making because we just wanted to make it
and we didn't care as much about like a
response to it we weren't
psychoanalyzing every little thing to
make sure that what we were doing
wouldn't potentially be awful we just
really wanted to get our vision out
there even if it was really amateur and
bad Orson Welles though coming from that
theater background knew how to tell a
story and knew how to put something
together and he knew how to make
something different that Hollywood
hadn't seen at the time I mean just the
fact that the film allows the audience
to become a part of the narrative like
early on with the news on the march
sequence where we're learning about the
life of Charles Foster Kane we're
hearing about his background how he was
raised his Millions his various
relationships this was a very unorthodox
approach to storytelling and story
structure people I think at first were
kind of confused by the movie and it
took a long time for the world to
realize how influential the movie
actually was now yes there's a major
plot hole in the film that has been
discussed a lot the fact that the film
opens with Charles Foster Kane dying and
saying the word rosebud and then starts
the entire basic story of the movie this
reporter who's attempting to figure out
what rosebud means and so he's visiting
all these figures that were integral to
Kane's life trying to figure out if he
can get a great story to publish about
what rosebud means the plot hole being
that he died alone and no one was around
and so we're kind of left to believe
that perhaps hit one of his maids or
Butler's may have heard him say this and
there's elements to the movie that you
can say well that's not good that's not
good there's too much exposition for
instance or maybe some of the
performances are a little hammy at times
but you just cannot deny the fact that
this movie was leaps and bounds ahead
of every other film in its time this
movie does not feel like a movie that
was released in 1941 it feels like a
film that could have been made today if
you strip away the obvious technical
stuff the black and white and some of
the sound and things that obviously
identify the time period the filmmaking
the precise cinematography use of cross
dissolves the way everything flows so
smoothly the way he moves in the camera
in someone when they're having an angry
moment or pulls back when there's a
softer moment on display Orson Welles
was ahead of his time he was a
perfectionist like all great filmmakers
one of his great annoyances with the
movie was that during the snowy scenes
early on despite the fact they look
really good you couldn't see the actors
breath because it was shot in a studio
and that pissed him off
because he's a perfectionist he wants it
to be as good as it can be which is a
sign of an excellent filmmaker and and
you can watch this in Kane today and say
well I didn't really appreciate that
that wasn't for me and I would
understand that because the first time I
saw it when I was younger I didn't
really get it it just wasn't for me but
as I got older I kept being drawn to it
and I wanted to see it again I had
similar experiences with Blade Runner
for instance didn't really appreciate
the movie on first viewing but it just
kept festering in my mind and Citizen
Kane is one of those movies and you
really can't deny the importance and the
impact fulness of this film I'm gonna
give a Citizen Kane and a-plus guys
thank you so much as always for
continuing to watch this series of
pre-1970s reviews I have one more to do
in December look forward to that as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]